With this barcoded ID,
a simple scan with a barcode reader
quickly pulls up the patient's records.
No need to rewrite their personal details
on paper registers at every visit.
And suddenly, queues became shorter.
This meant patients, typically mothers with little children on their backs,
had to spend less time waiting to be assisted.
And if they lose their booklets,
their records can still be pulled by searching with their names.
Now, the way we pronounce and spell names varies tremendously.
We freely mix R's and L's,
English and vernacular versions of their names.
Even soundex,
a standard method for grouping words by how similar they sound,
was not good enough.
So we had to modify it
to help us link and match existing records.
Before the iPhone,
software engineers developed for personal computers,
but from our experience,
we knew our power system is not reliable enough
for personal computers.
So we repurposed touch screen point-of-sale terminals
that are meant for retail shops
to become clinical workstations.
At the time, we imported internet appliances called i-Openers
that were manufactured during the dot-com era
by a failed US company.
We modified their screens
to add touch sensors
and their power system to run from rechargeable batteries.
When we started, we didn't find a reliable network to transmit data,
especially from rural hospitals.
So we built our own towers,
created a wireless network
and linked clinics in Lilongwe,
Malawi's capital.
(Applause)
With a team of engineers
working within a hospital campus,
we observed health care workers use the system
and iteratively build an information system
that is now managing HIV records
in all major public hospitals in Malawi.
These are hospitals serving over 2,000 HIV patients, each clinic.
Now, health care workers who used to spend days
to tally and prepare quarterly reports
are producing the same reports within minutes,
and health care experts from all over the world
are now coming to Malawi to learn how we did it.
(Applause)
It is inspiring and fun
to follow technology trends across the globe,
but to make them work
in low-resourced environments
like public hospitals in sub-Saharan Africa,
we have had to become jacks-of-all-trades
and build whole systems, including the infrastructure,
from the ground up.
Thank you.
(Applause)